i'm a huge fan of um musicals as well
big broadway fan very much looking
forward to the comeback
and i looked i saw your song list and i
thought this is really fascinating
because there are
closer classics here and songs that are
modern classics here as well and we
think about like broadway and musicals
people tend to think about
you know uh older songs when they're
going to cover things
but you've also got lin-manuel brandon
on here as well which is amazing
i'm curious has he heard your
version of wait for it what does he say
he has
he wrote i mean he's so gracious and and
was
so gracious to just to give us his
blessing first of all to rearrange this
you know and record it wait for it
but he heard it and he wrote back and he
said he was especially looking
for and looking forward to my specific
like take on the line about fire and
brimstone preacher
um i think you know that i was from the
south
you know the south of the us the
southeastern united states i think he
was waiting on that special swamp
and so i offered him a little swamp on
that so he was he was excited about that
and just excited for
you know the whole tone of the new
arrangement in general
how did you go about figuring out what
these arrangements were going to sound
like because some of them are so very
you know they're attached to the musical
that they're from
you might think of them that particular
way what was there like um
did you feel like we got to take our
freedom and make whatever we can make
out of this how did it go well you sort
of hit the nail on the head
it was a both end there and my
collaborative partner on this alex
lackamore whom
you will know he was the orchestrator
and arranger of hamilton of dear evan
hansen
of the movie the greatest showman of the
movie in the heights that's out now
um super super talented really a genius
at what he does
and and the way we approach this whole
project
was one of a twofold criteria could
we pay homage and respect to the
original composition
because let's be honest we in the
musical theater community are very
precious
about our productions you know about
about our canon if you will
and the legacy that they are so can we
respectfully pay homage to the original
but can we expand them in such a way
that they feel
fresh and new and there were some songs
that you know we were like we would try
things out and and very quickly and
and alex is so meticulous very quickly
we would know like
this feels a little too close to what
the original was this isn't fresh enough
this isn't new
enough um so we definitely wanted that
criteria and
and then we also wanted to meet a
criteria that that was
sometimes okay shows that felt personal
or balanced
musically i mean you'll hear like uh
there's a sucker born every minute
and basically it's sort of like a
palette cleanser if you're listening to
the album as an actual album you sort of
flip it
there and it feels like almost like a
two-act musical intermission
um but it has such levity to it we
wanted to make sure that that
musically and sonically the album
sounded diverse
and then there were other times where we
were like okay we need to make sure we
include
not only a balance of classics and
contemporaries but
you can't do an album like this and not
include sondheim like certain composers
that we were like okay we definitely
have to
make sure they are represented too so
that we put a lot of thought and
intention
you know in in really curating this
record yeah these songs are classics for
many reasons and you know you fall in
love with them for a lot of different
reasons too maybe you love the show
maybe you love the performance that you
saw
um but certainly because they have an
emotional impact on you is there a
particular song here
that hits you harder that hits you
hardest
yeah there are a couple and you know we
really sort of uh the
the a song for me there are two that i
think of in particular right now and and
of course it's very hard to choose what
your favorites are but i really feel
like oh what a beautiful morning
is such a joyous song of praise
and as we all sort of re-emerge out of
this pandemic and into what will
hopefully be
a safer world in some ways with vaccines
it feels like a new morning it feels
like absolutely a new dawn to a new day
and so the joy of that track to me and
the symbolism especially now as you know
broadway is about to
reopen in september um and which is a
super big deal because for broadway to
close
it's an iconic american institution that
has never been closed at 9 11
it never closed in any of the world wars
so
only at 9 11 so and maybe a blizzard
here or there randomly but
for it to close in the way that it did
is super symbolic
of just the impact that this pandemic
has had
all that is to say oh what a beautiful
morning boom celebration
let's you know let's get back out there
and re-emerge in the world
and then i feel conversely like the song
tomorrow which is the last track on the
record it's tomorrow from little orphan
annie but it's not the
you know the little girl screaming along
like we all in talent shows you know
it's a super mature somber
it's really a take on that song that
allows for for
an interpretation of longing in the
lyric in a way that says like
i have the experience
and and yet at the same time i still
have the courage enough to hope
yeah is it is the timing um of this
release intentional i know it's been
finished for a while
and then like you said you know broadway
didn't it was one of the rare occasions
where broadway shuts down
and now we're looking at hopefully being
on the other side of things
and the whole world getting back to
feeling like normal if not acting like
normal so
what does the timing mean the timing is
really cosmic carlos and let me tell you
even a back story even beyond that so i
was mentioning the song tomorrow it's
the last track on the album but it was
also the last track that i recorded
so we recorded this album in in 2019
into early 2020. i sang the last note of
that song
which was the last note of that we
recorded of the album
on march 12th 2020 and i walked
out of the vocal booth and into the
sound booth and all of our phones
started lighting up saying broadway is
closing
broadway is closing officially closing
and it was just
like it's a chill moment it's one of
those moments that everybody was just
like
whoa okay so i really feel like there is
an intrinsic
universal connection between this album
and obviously broadway because that's
the music but but between
this album and the journey that we have
all been on and that broadway has been
on
as as we have been shut down as so many
of us all over the world you know
have suffered in so many ways but as
that community
definitely has struggled because live
entertainment is the last
you know to come back in terms of
industries so i feel like there's a
beautiful spiritual connection between
this album and and that process
is it surreal for you to be able to say
that you are putting your spin
and releasing these songs because like
i think for people that look at you that
are fans of yours maybe young fans of
yours
they go oh that's my dream is to be that
right but then i imagine for you a lot
of what you do is born
out of your dreams when you were
listening to this music and watching
these shows
oh my god yes and born out of also a
whole artistic
arc and trajectory you know some people
may know me from from the ways that i
came on to what i call the mainstream
public consciousness which was
in sugar land and a lot of times what
can happen is is you do
a project that has has success and it's
wonderful
to have success and at the same time you
get put in what i call the shining silo
of success
and everybody's like stay in your lane
when in reality you know i was i grew up
doing musical theater i did it all
through
high school and college as well in
community i had been
playing out in an in an independent band
you know and making a living as a
musician for 10 years before i came
onto the scene you know where sugarland
was concerned as a writing project
and then so the point is it's like you
may only know
me in one way but that trajectory and
arc
is really big as an artist and for
artists our whole
i believe process is one of continual
change
continual expansion continual evolution
thus the name always like new and
this album is concerned we are always
reinventing ourselves and much like
these songs many of which are classics
but then
revisited to do all that is to say in
terms of anybody who might
think oh i want to be this and do this
yes what i would say that this
is is be an artist
go with your heart put put you know the
the the art in heart okay
and and really what it is that you love
and don't stay in your lane
don't stay in your lane those who stay
in in their lanes it's just
it's it's i don't believe it serves the
art
hmm and my dad used to call it the
golden handcuffs
say they're the golden handcuffs yeah
that's just the gilded cage like
it's it's gold it's beautiful but it's
still a cage
i'm gonna use that carla yeah yeah you
can have it
now i was i was wondering your your book
ends your mom
and your son did you consult with them
about which songs go here like which
ones are their favorites
oh you know i mean now my son has seen
so many productions he has seen so many
broadway shows everything that is age
appropriate and beyond he has seen so
many i mean
lion king wicked little shop of cars
beetlejuice frozen
aladdin or lion king wicket did i say
wicked
like you you name it he has he has seen
it um so he
loves musicals um but i don't know that
he knows as many of the classics and he
hasn't been able to see
you know the dear evan hansen's or the
hamiltons yet because he's only eight so
he hasn't seen as many of those classics
so he really didn't have that input but
my mom
you know she was actually speaking of of
tomorrow the first
album that i ever owned and held in my
little hands
was of the soundtrack of little orphan
annie
so for me you know
and the exposure that she gave me to
musical theater and always carting me
around to every single production you
know i was in of it here's greece and
here's oliver and here's you know
barnum and all these different you know
community theater productions that i was
in even as a young girl before before
high school in college
um you know she was absolutely
instrumental in
in the inspirations behind an album such
as this
of everything that you've done and
everything that you've released where
does this rank
for uh for her for her
yeah oh my god she loves it she loves it
also a celebrity i mean but listen she's
biased okay she's my mama so she loves
everything i do every single thing is
the best one ever
every single new project is like this is
the best you've ever done so
it's it's a little bit you know you have
to like curve for the but for the bias
there oh
where yeah oh yeah yeah but you know
this project too vocally oh my god
what an absolute indulgence and treat
carlos because when you think about it
you know anything that falls under the
umbrella of modern popular music pop
country you know r b anything that would
be like quote unquote on the radio so to
speak or
streamers whatever it is nowadays um
it's
very rigid in its structure first chorus
first chorus bridge chorus
melodically in terms of vocals it stays
it has a pretty
limited line and yet musical theater is
not like that it's like it rambles it
goes to other places
it's soars there's no reason at all on a
country record for me to sing
the e above c above middle c which is
yes
you know getting into the top of my
range but in musical theater
absolutely and you'll hear it on this
record so vocally
this this song is like and it is an
absolute party
does that must feel like it must feel
like getting the chance to sprint
you know like when people are used to
seeing you do a particular type of run
whatever it is but you're like i can
sprint guys look at this look at me go
yes it is like removing the pace car if
you will
and like letting me just blow it's like
it
or it's like if you think about a horse
you know what i'm saying it's just like
removing it all and just like running
absolutely
as fast as you can so then you know what
are the chances of getting christian
from sugarland to join you for a
broadway follow-up
instead of a country follow-up instead
of a wait say that again instead of a
country follow-up
yeah the next sugar land project being
something we we have in the cantu
waiting you know waiting for sugarland
is concerned so that'll probably be the
next thing although you know
he's been enjoying expanding in terms of
the musical theater world and has been
doing some stuff
um in atlanta for some some theater work
down there too so we're you know we're
all growing and expanding
you